à la force de son seul coup de [ __ ]
Robert va tenter de toaster une tartine
[Musique]
5,9% c'est notre chiffre du jour il
s'agit de l'inflation sur un an au mois
de décembre une hausse des prix qui
ralentit pour comparaison elle était de
6,2% en novembre et en octobre mais
attention à ne pas se réjouir trop vite
puisque cette baisse pourrait naître que
provisoire et puis dans le détail les
prix de l'alimentaire ont augmenté de
12,1%, et ceux de l'énergie de 15,1%
quand tu arrives à des situations où
près de 50% de ton chiffre d'affaires de
ce que tu collectes tu le redonnes à
totale énergie qui se gave comme un
sapare et j'ai pas de termes pardon
parce que moi j'ai vu j'ai vu la
pardon j'ai vu la tristesse de ces chefs
d'entreprise ils ont fermé 10 ils ont
fermé 10 ils ont fermé parce qu'ils
peuvent pas rouvrir il va réussir à
maintenir le grille-pain allumé à pleine
puissance pendant une minute et 48
secondes
avant de s'effondrer de fatigue
quant à la tartine
elle est tout juste dorée moi j'ai honte
j'ai honte c'est pourquoi parce que j'ai
défendu total énergie il est super
profits ici je les ai défendus et moi
j'étais dans les mails se font massacrer
alors pour y aller arrête de te gaver et
laisse ces artisans travailler
et qui viennent avec moi qui viennent
faire la tournée parle je suis désolé
pour produire l'électricité que nous
consommons chaque jour individuellement
chacun de nous devrait avoir à son
service
285 Robert
ça prendrait de la place
bonjour se sortir les doigts du fond
excusez-moi de vulgaire
économie et quelque part parce que je
sais pas ce qu'on attend William sera
ferme carbitre ferme enfin on parle pas
de la fromagerie de Johnny blanc on
parle des boîtes avec lui
petite révolution dans les enseignes de
restauration rapide depuis le 1er
janvier fini les emballages jetables
trop polluants place à la vaisselle
réutilisable vert couvert et barquettes
de frites mais pas question de les
emporter avec soi il faut les laisser
sur place on est très fiers de vous
présenter Katsumi notre promesse vous
faire adorer réutiliser vos capsules de
café à l'intérieur vous avez trois
capsules réutilisables à l'infini un
shaker pour les remplir facilement et de
quoi faire vos 45 premières capsules de
café juste en dessous à la sortie de
cette enseigne ce couple n'a pas compris
le message il est parti avec un verre
nouvelle génération
nous a rien dit on nous sorti une
personne ne nous a rien dit donc je
pense que ça va être normal c'est
réutilisable donc à l'intérieur dans le
McDo ou chez nous ça revient au même ça
sera un nouveau souvenir je vous propose
200000 euros et pour 13%. ce que je
pense que vraiment il y a une vraie
valeur et j'ai envie de remporter ce
deal et donc je vais pas m'aligner avec
Marc parce que je j'ai pas l'impression
que je veux plus et donc pour remporter
ce deal je vais améliorer la proposition
donc 200000 euros pour 13%. en ce moment
même se tient à Las Vegas le ces le
grand salon des technologies parmi
lesquels celle-ci vous allez voir que
nous vivons vraiment une époque
formidable un four équipé d'une caméra
pour diffuser en direct la cuisson de
vos plats sur internet c'est pas beau le
progrès diffuser des fours en direct je
veux pas gâcher la fête mais c'est ce
que je fais chaque soir en direct je
diffuse mes propres fours Théo allez
viens là je te fasse mon arme
super [ __ ] et à trois on dégaine tu es
prêt à 3 1 2 3 stop oh la vache
aujourd'hui trouver un contact dans
l'industrie c'est parce que plus
compliqué on va dire du coup voilà merci
beaucoup pour votre offre mais on a des
clim merci beaucoup
[Rires]
[Musique]
d'autres tu en as connu d'autres je sais
pas trop le relevé
les banquiers ils font pas leur job on
m'a coupé la tête pour des millions et
ben alors donnez le nom de la banque
vous voyez ce que je veux dire
le PDG de la banque il est en train de
nous écouter et lui-même il est pas au
courant sans doute il est pas au courant
et si vous écoute il va vous aider donc
au moins conserver quelque chose c'est
la première fois de ma vie que je
servirai à quelque chose non je blague
merci beaucoup pour la confiance que que
vous m'accordez ça me fait plaisir et je
suis sûr que mes collègues auraient
vraiment fait un formidable travail et
si on a besoin d'eux il nous aideront
gratuitement je le sais parce que ce
sont des gens
[Rires]
pour 2023
il a pas que des bonnes nouvelles une
nouvelle pandémie à venir qui se cache
pour l'instant on Antarctique et qui se
cache pour l'instant et que le virus il
est au frais là-bas le virus zombie
est-ce qu'on va revenir d'entre les
morts se manger moi c'est la question
qu'on peut se poser écoutez bien
l'ouverture d'un portail vers un autre
monde qui se situerait apparemment vers
la zone 51 vous savez c'est une base
militaire très mystérieux
ce policier démontre sa méthode pour
ouvrir la vitre d'une voiture ou se
recoin c'est un enfant pour cela vous
aurez besoin de deux ventouses et de
deux petits bouts de scotch résultat
effectivement ça fonctionne encore
faut-il avoir sur soi devant tous
des policiers imaginent un nouvel
équipement réglementaire
quand d'autres s'inquiètent des
mauvaises intentions de certains le
meilleur pour la fin non je vous ai
gardé quand même le meilleur pour la fin
parce que ça c'est très sympa c'est
l'arrivée de l'Antéchrist celui qui
usure fera l'identité du Christ et qui
en fait un énorme mais après les textes
sacrés voilà c'est très simple on a
vraiment hâte qu'il arrive précédemment
on peut y croire les deux équipes
finalistes bon ça c'est concret mais là
c'est un peu pipeau c'est un peu plus
farfelu mais on dit que 2023 c'est
peut-être la fin du monde
c'est super